hi everyone I'm Maurice Samuels the
director of the Yale program for the
study of anti-Semitism and I want to
welcome you to this special webinar
entitled anti-Semitism after October 7 I
know that while the war is still going
on it's hard to think about anything
except anxiety and grief but we
nevertheless need to begin to take stock
of the way that the massacre of October
7th has profoundly changed the way Jews
view the world and the way the World
Views Jews to help us sort through this
complex situation I've invited Kenneth
Stern to speak with us today he's an
author an attorney and serves as the
Director of The Bard center for the
study of hate previously he was director
of the division on anti-Semitism and
extremism at the American Jewish
committee where he worked for 25 years
Mr Sterns op EDS and book reviews have
appeared in the New York Times The
Washington Post the forward and the
Jewish telegraphic agency and other
places too his newest book the conflict
over the conflict the Israel Palestine
campus debate was published in 2020 I'm
very grateful to Ken for agreeing to
join us on very little notice today I
can think of few people better qualified
to discuss the issue of
anti-Semitism so here's how the webinar
will work uh I will engage Ken in
discussion for about 30 minutes uh then
we'll take 30 minutes of questions from
the audience and we'll end right around
6: PM so please submit questions at any
time during the discussion using the Q&A
function at the bottom of your screen
and I will relay the questions during
the the question period the chat
function has been disabled and I should
say that American Sign Language uh
interpretation is being provided live
and can be accessed by pinning the ASL
interpreters so I realize this topic has
aroused a lot of passion but I want to
discuss it today in as calm and rational
a manner as possible and I urge you to
write questions in that Spirit um and I
urge you to keep the questions focused
on the issue of anti-Semitism you know
there are many other topics like the how
you know Israel should conduct the war
things like that that we really can't
get to today so with that said let's
start uh the discussion there's there's
a lot to get
to so hi thank you thank you thank you
for inviting me and thank you for giving
me the opportunity to talk with your
audience I'm you know I'm a fan of your
work and I'm just honored to be able to
have this discussion with you tonight oh
well thank you so much um and welcome to
everybody here um so let's get started
so right after October 7th as the horror
of the massacre emerged uh there was an
outpouring of revulsion against Hamas
and sympathy for Israel then things
began to change when Israel's bombing of
Gaza started um since then we've seen
some really scary anti-semitic incidents
around the world um including just in
the last few days things it seems like
things have been getting dramatically
worse um the attack on the airport in
dagistan was particularly scary and in
the US things have gotten very scary uh
the Anti-Defamation League last week
reported a 388 per increase in
anti-semitic attacks since October 7th
compared with a year earlier so can you
start by just saying what you think is
going on um how worried should we be um
is this a blip or a sea change um maybe
another way of saying that is don't we
always see a spike in violence against
Jews after conflicts of the Middle East
and then things settle down so but maybe
not I don't know how do you see
things well it's very hard to predict
the future so you know we're at a moment
now in the middle of things being
totally shaken up but you're right if
you look
historically um there was a con conern
in the 73 yamkipur War where there was
the Arab Oil Embargo and those of us who
are old enough to remember you know we
had to go on even days and odd days to
fill up our tanks and that was a concern
that Jews were going to be blamed and
they really weren't um There Was You
know the attacks that happened really
after the beginning of the second inata
after the peace process collapsed and
there was a spike to me was very
reminiscent of what we're seeing Maybe
on a somewhat smaller scale but it was I
remember the places in the United States
in North America having some synagogues
that were being attacked much more so in
Europe and then what happened was in the
US after a few weeks after the shooting
stopped it dissipated not so much uh in
in Europe a little bit but it still was
at a level lot higher than before um
what may be different now uh is that
we're at a point where the
uh you know the end of of what's
happening is not
clear and so uh you know the continuing
seeing of uh pictures of civilians in
Gaza uh being pulled out of rubble and
babies and hospitals and so forth I
think are going to contribute to uh some
of the you know continued attention to
this um and you know on on campuses
where we've seen issues
before
the couple of the I think it was you
know
200 uh you know see 20 I have a note
down here 2014 yeah the the attack the
war with Kaza is it was in July campus
was out and in 2008 it was January so
campus was out so that's one of the
other different factors here now
students are very much on campus and
organizing around this so so on that
question I know a lot of people are just
shocked by what's going on on college
campuses um are how do you see it are
campuses hot beds of anti-Semitism is it
only at certain campuses is it you know
it seems like the IV League campuses are
getting the most attention but um and
certainly what happened to Cornell this
week with those you know horrifying
threats you know from a another student
so how do you understand what's
happening on college
campuses well you're right I mean some
of the the incidents we've seen have
been particularly disgusting the Cornell
one in particular but there have been
others too threats of violence and so
forth um but in some ways you know this
this isn't new I mean you mentioned that
I wrote a book on the conflict over the
conflict uh in 2020 and there was a
already again not on every College on
4,000 colleges Israel is a not a big
issue on most of them but on some of
them it is and on those campuses uh
what's been transpiring for a number of
years is the sort of binary view uh
where you know people get into their
buckets of thinking ah you know this
only Justice on the Palestinian side
there's no justice on the Israeli side
or vice versa um and trying to suppress
speech on you know each side so we've
had had over the years although not as
ubiquitous as some people would would uh
portray incidents where Israeli or or
pro-israel speakers were shouted down at
heckler's veto we've had uh attempts to
um professors who were decided that
their politics are more important to
them than the responsibility to their
students so I'm not going to write a
letter of recommendation for somebody to
go study in in Israel you've had a a
push from time to time to have academic
boycotts of of Israel
because um you know people were so upset
with the variety of things that Israel
stands for or is done not recognizing
that in an academic setting the purpose
of it is to look at ideas when you
segregate a a nationality that's an
agregation so we had that on you know on
one side we' also had actually last year
more of an escalation too where you've
had it
Berkeley uh Vermont and and news some
decisions to exclude zionists from
spaces you like climate change or sexual
Survivor spaces which tells me that you
know that's sort of McCarthyism it's
they they have a right to Define their
political groups but when you say you
know Zionist shouldn't be in this space
it's the same as saying the 50s
communist can't be in the space even it
has nothing to do with with this you
know the politics on the flip side
of this binary which I think is very
CTIC to the campus you've had uh
attempts by the organized Jewish
Community um to suppress some you know
prop Palestinian speech um and there a
whole long history of trying to use the
What's called the IRA definition of
anti-semitism which I was the lead
drafter of in its early text in its
earlier iteration and trying to use it
as a speech code to stop certain speech
on campus and you just had you know I I
think well most people on this call
would find the the students for justice
in Palestine statements over the last
couple weeks reprehensible or worse but
you had uh Jonathan greenblat going and
uh Ken Marcus telling universities to go
investigate you had disantis kicking off
SJP groups that's also a violation of
academic freedom so you've had you know
this sort of divide beforehand but it's
become on steroids now on the
campus and and that certainly you know
was um you know the case with the
reaction to the Harvard students who you
know came out right pretty soon after
October 7th um with you know um a
statement blaming Israel for the attacks
and then there was you know really a
backlash against them and you know
attempts to make their identities known
so people don't don't hire them what
Would You Do you think that was an
overreaction on the part of um the
Jewish Community there or or Jewish
donors to those to the Harvard students
and if so what would have been a a
better uh
response yeah I think it was pretty
awful I mean these are 18 19 and 20 year
olds um and you're going after them and
saying they shouldn't be employed they
should have a you know a mark against
it's a blacklist I mean what the reason
why I'm against the academic boycott is
also because it's a blacklist and I
don't think you fight Blacklist you know
with Blacklist the doxing and the the
inherent threat of violence that comes
you know where you live and we're going
to put a truck in front of your house uh
to you know to me is uh disgusting but
that's not new I mean there's a thing
called Canary Mission which has been
around and um has identified uh students
that the canary Mission folks have
objection to their some of their speech
and I share a lot of their objections
but when you create a list that sort of
marks them um that's so what's a better
what should do that yeah yeah so I think
you speak out against it I think you
encourage others to speak out against
you know that that type of speech you
don't try to um you know to to penalize
it because it is Free Speech but you use
on an academy you use the tools you have
at hand right you use the
educational process to uh mine uh in a
very difficult moment and there are
things that you can do shortterm and
things that you can do you know
long-term shortterm I know a uh some a
colleague of ours Susanna hesel and a
few others immediately did a very good
program at Dartmouth um there have been
places Bard and other places too that
have done visuals uh I think Williams as
well um and at Bard last Thursday I mean
The Bard has had a lot of lot of
programs um this one that we put
together was looking at um the issue of
laws of war and islamophobia and
anti-Semitism in the aftermath of this
and I had a subtext for that it was very
crowded it was you know it was intense
discussion but I wanted students to get
out of their binary boxes uh and not to
feed the binary so the binary you know
again are Israel is 100% responsible
this is all about the occupation it's
all about you know settler or
colonialism and then the other side is
the wait a minute this is how could you
not uh condemn you know baby killing and
some of the I don't know if you saw the
Lincoln's testimony about some of the
more gruesome uh things that happened
you know not condemn that so what I
wanted the students to realize was that
a course run a center for hate that you
know this is not the first time hate has
gotten to this point where the bombs are
happening and people are getting shot
and there are atrocities and there's
actually a rule of how you you know you
deal with these things and that's the
the rules of law so I wanted them to to
see that and where both sides uh may not
be you know or certainly not well one
the Kamas clearly in Israel you can
point to certain questions about whether
they're living up to the laws of war and
then on the anti-Semitism and
islamophobia I wanted them to understand
uh precisely how hatred works you you
know when I I when I have discussions
about this topic and actually a lot of
discussions around you know the book um
I go back to the the first chapter which
is uh about how when our identity is
Tethered to an issue of of social
justice or Injustice our brains actually
function differently this brain science
as Jo so that there's social psychology
there are other
fields that show we you know our brains
fire differently that we try to reduce
things to Simplicity and all right and
all wrong we're allergic to
complexity uh and we just get further
and further into our own Bubbles and
when you sort of understand that that's
what happens when you feel this way I
think it creates an intellectual space
to be able to uh engage with that more
so that was one of the things I shared
with the students and also about the the
uptick and anti-Semitism and
islamophobia um I mean there have been
uh the murder of that you know
six-year-old uh child and I have a a
friend in the UK who um monitors online
anti-Semitism and islamophobia both of
course have spite tremendously but he
said this is the first time you've seen
them happen in tandem yeah the the the
point I wanted students to Come Away
with is this is how hatred works this
animates a certain number of people to
feel Justified to act on it with things
of violence you may not act you're not
going to act you a violent way but some
of the things that stir them are
probably going on with you and I wanted
them to be able to reflect so things
like that and I could talk about more
things you do on campus yeah so what
about just you know a kind of basic
vexing question in anti-i ISM studies is
how do you distinguish between
legitimate criticism of Israel's
policies even the war and anti-Semitism
and you know where do we put that line
and has I I this is obviously a question
I know you've thought a lot about but
has the recent War changed how you've
thought about this question it hasn't
changed how I thought about it I think
and and I wrote a piece um for an
Israeli Think Tank a couple years ago
about this that
basically that you know anti-Semitism at
its core uh is two things right it's
conspiracy theory that believe Jews are
conspiring to harm humanity and gives an
explanation for what goes wrong in the
world from missing you know Christian
children back in the blood liel days to
Margery K green and Jewish space lasers
right so you know that's the core of of
how anti-Semitism works so if one is cut
and pasting Israel and putting that
place that's that's
fine on the other side of the spectrum
there are Palestinian folks who are
saying wait a
minute
Zionism means that basically Jews came
and disrupted our ability to control our
lives and you know for that's why they
are anti-zionists they don't believe
that there should be a Jewish dat they
believe that Jews should be Ed like this
the ones that I converse with no they
believe in a uh you know one state with
everybody getting a vote now that's a
problem for Jew I mean certainly a
problem for Jews before October 7th when
you know who's going to trust that
that's going to work out hunky dory um
but you know to me that that you can
make the argument that it's functionally
anti-semitic and anti-palestinian
because it it it's going to be perpetual
uh Warfare but does that mean that
they're motivated by hatred of Jews no
um and when I teach about this I use a
essay by Derek penslar of Harvard it's
sort of a what if essay and he talks
about uh what if it had been instead of
Jews coming back to their historic
Homeland it had been a a Protestant
group called The Templars that had come
and reconstituted there would it have
been more like the reaction to
rodesia uh so you know the to me there's
you clear instances where anti-zionism
is anti-Semitism clear instances where
anti-zionism is not
anti-Semitism and there's a whole bunch
of gray in the middle depending on
intent and context and so forth yeah so
so one of those instances so last week
on the Yale campus there was a a p Pro
Palestine walk out um they called it I I
saw it and
um there were signs saying from The
River To The Sea Palestine will be free
um and many including the
Anti-Defamation League consider this
slogan
anti-semitic um I think they see it as a
kind of dog whistle implying the
extermination of Jews or at least the
Eraser of Israel um but other people
don't see that as anti-semitic so how
that seems to be one of the you know
kind of gray areas how do you understand
that that SL a concrete example Le yeah
I mean precisely it's ambiguous because
somebody could mean we just yeah from
The River To The Sea we're going to wipe
out all the Jews and take it over that's
one way that that could be interpreted
it could also mean from the river and
the Sea we're going to have a Democratic
Society with this one person one vote
and so you know the the context of it is
important um you know and I think one of
the problems with you looking about
anti-Semitism is again you know we want
to get into that Comfort space where we
say oh it's clearly anti-semitic or ah
it's not anti-semitic at all and there
are a lot of things that are much more
ambiguous and I think to the extent that
we say okay how do we look at
this problem uh rather than sticking in
one pin or another and then moving on I
think the the better were able to
understand it and what to do about it
okay um so I'm going to shift a little
bit to talk about um the American
government's reaction to October 7th um
and you know I think it was pretty you
know striking that the Biden
Administration has been you know very
strongly at least initially um
supportive of um of Israel in the wake
of the attack how do you um understand
that so this is now we're talking about
maybe the opposite of anti-semitism here
um is it and do you see it beginning to
weaken now um well I I you know I I was
impressed where the Biden Administration
other some other foreign leaders too uh
came out because they you know see a lot
of different interests involved one is
just on the moral tone the slaughter and
the
brutality uh was you know absolutely
revolting um and you know as a leader I
presume you think what would you do if
that happened to your people and what
would the
responsibilities be uh so the
full-throated support of Israel to be
able to deal with this is is not
surprising now the devil is in the
details right so there's um you know I'm
again you don't want to go too far into
the conflict situation but I'm not
convinced that one can wipe out Hamas
it's an idea and maybe they something
worse that comes I'm not sure what the
plans are for the day after but I've
also seen the Biden
Administration you know uh to my
satisfaction at least uh publicly
talking about there these are the
lessons from Afghanistan this what this
is this is you know the rabbit hole you
may be going down you know don't make
the same mistakes we did and then also
having you know concerns for um
civilians and
um you know
so whether that's going to change the
bombing continues I don't know I mean um
it's certainly a possibility uh that it
may change and one of the calculations
again is that you've seen some you know
Progressive Democrats yeah who are you
know I fully understand it seeing the
the you know when you see dead babies
and you don't think Jesus should stop um
there's a you know there's a challenge
there and some of those folks are saying
they're so upset with Biden for not
stopping Israel from this uh response
that they're never going to vote for him
and so is that going to be something
that's going to be this is you know the
support of Israel if he loses the
election some are going to have that
narrative right and is you know I mean
it just seems to me like okay so that
means that Trump will be elected next
time is that going to be great for
Progressive causes that seems to be a
you know a really you know I understand
that you know perhaps they you know
these Progressive groups feel like they
need to threaten loss of support for
Biden but you know I think that that
just seems like a completely irrational
response but any that's my own
editorializing yeah yeah um so let's
talk a little bit more about um Jewish
groups who are anti-zionist or you know
maybe not even anti-zionist but really
oppose this this war and are calling for
a ceasefire um how do you understand
that is that um you know do you put that
in the same category as you know um
different forms of anti Zionism that do
cross the line to anti-Semitism I guess
another way of saying that is um are
there um you know do you see that uh are
Jews exempt from anti-Semitism or how do
you how do you understand that um Jewish
uh anti-zionist response yeah Jews are
aren exempt from anti-Semitism Jews
could be anti-semitic just like you know
black people could be racist and so
forth that being said I see debate
inside the Jewish community and this is
one of the things that disturbs me about
some of the you know the pushing of the
definition on for application on
campuses saying uh to be Jewish means
means you have to have an identity with
Israel you have to be a
Zionist I'm a Zionist Israel is part of
my Jewish identity but I realize that
for some Jews that's not in fact the
case and you know I interviewed a number
of them when I was putting together the
book and and the again I don't have data
for this particular thing but a lot of
anecdotes and the anecdotes you know
sort of go something like this um I went
to Jewish days school a lot of the
people in ifn not now uh in particular
and also jbp I think some um you know
had Jewish Education and some of them uh
are children and grandchildren of Jewish
communal uh staff and L leaders had a
Jewish
Education I go to college and for the
first time I hear there's something
called an occupation and I feel betrayed
and what's going on and I learned about
how we treat the stranger I learned
about repairing the world I can't
justify the existence of a Jewish State
on top of a Palestinian population uh as
something that comports with my Judaism
now I can argue with them I can disagree
with them but who am I to say that
they're you know outside the tent of
what being Jewish should
mean yeah um okay and maybe one last
question that I'll ask you before going
to the um uh to the questions from the
audience I do urge you all to um put
questions in the Q&A function um so who
has a right to talk about these issues
you know um I think that a lot of Jews
feel like um you know are suspicious
when uh you know they can certainly
understand why Palestinians maybe all
Arabs are concerned about this they can
maybe understand why other Jews are
concerned about this on both sides but I
think there's Sometimes some suspicion
why non-jews are so energized about this
question and how do you see that like
who has a right to you know talk about
these issues on on campuses or or
elsewhere I think anybody has a right to
talk about these issues but the you know
sort of if you look back at the sort of
timeline of where um you know there sort
of been a leftwing critique of of Israel
it's an interesting timeline and it goes
a lot with the the politics and
Progressive Movement which I consider
myself part of
historically if you look back at the
national lawyers Guild resolution of
1948 and the lawyers Guild is a
progressive organization that uh has
been you know very much in the Forefront
of of of work opposing the Israeli you
know government um 1948 resolution reads
like a leon Europe novel it's it's like
you support the hag the Arabs are
attacking why because at that moment in
time Israel was seen as socialist and an
anti-colonialist and the Russians were
you know supportive and so that was the
political
Dynamic then then you have uh I think 67
was a watershed where a lot of uh
progressives and you know nonaligned
countries and so forth said what's going
on here and started to see the this is a
you know flip to to adopting the
Palestinian narrative as opposed to the
uh Israeli one um then you started
seeing um you know the left I mean if
you look at the the political statement
of the Weather Underground it reads like
a contemporary thing from
SJP um so it's been part of the I think
you know there were times where there
were certain movements that people Co
coales around South Africa um uh
anti-war and so forth and this has the
imagination partly because I think a lot
of people are
concerned um because you know the holy
land is is an important place it's a US
Ally gets a lot of money gets a lot of
attention um but there's you know it's
also become one of those
binary you know good and bad uh you know
symbols and again when we're talking
about a a campus the thing to me is to
try to break down that binary to show
it's more you know complicated so there
are have been some efforts to do that
but I I'll give you one thing that came
up in in um my talk at at at Bard I mean
one of the simple or binary how do we
look at this and we don't have to think
about it is Israel's a settler colonial
state end of story okay so it's it's you
know indigenous people are being
hurt and I have in my book I have the
two competing narratives and they're you
know they're they sort of fly by each
other at night but I had this couet that
I I pointed out to a student who was
pushing this and um I talked about the
fact that there was a there a group
called Abby the Palestinian campaign for
the academic and cultural boycott of
Israel it sent a letter to the iroy
Confederacy in New York um because the
IR folks have uh lacrosse is they claim
to have invented it they're very much
involved in international lacrosse there
was going to be an international
lacrosse tournament in uh Tel Aviv and
they said you're indigenous like us
you're a victim of settler colonialism
like us it will be a betrayal for you to
come don't and then I contrast it with a
an article short couple paragraphs from
uh Judea Pearl may know as the at UCLA
or did at his son Daniel Pearl was the
journalist who was beheaded and he said
name me another settler colonial state
where you have people speaking the
language that was spoken there before
the you know so-called indigenous folks
name me another place where people have
been talking about in their poetry and
lore and religion for you know thousands
of years of settler colonialist name me
another place where um you name cities
New York New Berlin New Baghdad you know
not those things but names that they had
in you know times of the Bible um and
then I quote a a historian who says um
Real History is the ability to navigate
both those things simultaneously the
rest is communal advocacy and the more I
think we can underscore that complexity
to to look at and really understand the
narratives that that's a good thing and
one one final Point too is I tell
students um uh and I've been speaking on
a lot of campuses even before this that
you know none of them are going to solve
the Israeli Palestinian conflict all of
them have control over how they treat
their classmates it's fine if they have
strong you know political views on this
um and you know as part of being a a
good Advocate don't they want to engage
with people who have a different point
of view you learn more from people that
have a different point of view uh than
from people that agree with you and I
tell him I used to be a criminal trial
lawyer you know if I
didn't I was if I didn't think about how
the prosecution would present its case
and was just focusing on what I wanted
to say but not having the imagination to
think about how they were going to
approach it I would have been committing
malpractice so the more you make it as
an educational good to have the
emotional capacity and the intellectual
curiosity um the better off I think
things will be yeah okay so we have a a
lot of questions
um and several of the questions are
grouped around this issue so someone
says um yesterday Harvard and upan
announced the formation of advisory
boards to combat
anti-Semitism why isn't the battle
against
anti-Semitism included or already
included as part of existing Dei so
diversity equity and inclusion
infrastructure so as everyone maybe
people who aren't part of universities
don't know that there is you know there
is a whole Dei infrastructure on every
campus and Jews seem to be left out of
that so why do we you know why is that
it it depends on where there's some
places where where you know
anti-Semitism is included I've done some
training for some places and some places
where it's not and there places before
you know this that have decided they've
really wanted to wrestle with issues of
anti-Semitism and lilac cor and Burman
at a temple put together a uh commission
that really looked at at the issue and
and it really just isn't you know a
question of support for students which
is important uh or to think about it for
administrators but it's also to to think
about it for curriculum I think there
needs to be more classes on
anti-Semitism but there also needs to be
more classes on how do you have
difficult discussions on issues that cut
you to the core um about the importance
of academic freedom and free speech
about uh uh I think part of The
Challenge on campus and I I think this
is partly some of of what goes under Dei
and I'm again supportive of a lot of it
but I see sometimes where the message is
students should not be disturbed by
ideas if you're going to be disturbed by
ideas you know oh my God we got to
protect you you're fragile to me you
know nobody should be harassed nobody
should be discriminated against nobody
should be threatened uh nobody should be
bullied but if you're not getting
disturbed by ideas on college campus you
know why are you spending all that money
to go there right but do you think that
um I mean several people have pointed
out that um Jews don't seem to be
treated as a minority worthy of um you
know uh um you know diversity um
sensitivity on campus you know is do you
do you feel like that's true um you know
um like and that certain things that you
know people have pointed out that are
you know you would never hear about
other minority groups are kind of
tolerated when it comes to to Jews on
campuses it it depends on the campus and
it depends on the context so um you know
there a lot of
Campus a lot of campuses that have have
a lot of lot of Jews um there are some
in you know tendency among some folks on
the left to uh again to go into these
binary spaces where Jews are white Jews
are privileged how can you have uh
discrimination against them that's
that's not new um and that's hurtful
when you know 20 30 years ago when I was
doing training um saying you know for a
Jewish student who hears that something
that happens to them uh can't possibly
be hurtful because they're white um
that's doubly dismissive because they
think that the people that ought to you
know know understand don't so that that
happens in some places but I I for you
know the majority of what I've been able
to see again I haven't done a survey of
all 4,000 campuses um is that if there's
something that's clearly anti-semitic
you know white uh white supremacist uh
you know leafleting or something that'll
be dealt when it comes to Israel it's
much more complicated and it's again you
have Jewish students who are taking the
position that is anti-zionist I mean
there's a whole Kur fuffle about that
speech at the Cy graduate uh at the law
school where the you know somebody was
giving us varant anti-israel speech and
the Jewish law student group was
supportive of it so you have a variety
um and you also have Palestinian
students and when you have
um you know a push back on something
that's not clearly anti-semitic but may
make Jewish students who have a Israel
identity is part of um then you you know
do something to harm the Palestinian
students too so the the better response
is not just to think about how am I
going to go flagged that type of speech
is how do I bring people together to
have you know conversations how should I
change the Academy so that people know
they're not going to be harassed but
they are going to be disturbed and then
what are we going to do with that you
know being disturbed and and what about
um you know someone is asking um if you
really do you know feel that
um the you know there should be an
immediate ceasefire uh in the war right
now and then some people are saying that
that's anti-semitic to to say that how
do you
how do you respond to that God I'm glad
I don't have to make you know those
decisions about what to do or what not
to do in this context you know I I as a
human being I'm concerned
about uh you know the the you know the
civilians that are dying in in Gaza uh
it's
heartbreaking um I think you know Israel
has a right to defend it I I was asking
an ethicist who's philosopher friend of
mine you know the beginning of this I
said to get out the hostages that's an
obligation for you know any country but
you know when you do that you're going
to cause a lot of Civilian damages how
do you how do you away that you know and
he said basically Heck if I know there's
a rule of War so that there's you know
Israel went after commanders but a lot
of collateral damage how many you know
so I don't know what to but I don't
think I there are some that are you know
clearly don't want Israel to do anything
at all and to me you know that may be an
indication of something that uh is
problematic because if you know United
States were attacked from Canada and
then say Oh don't respond that that
wouldn't be an appropriate response but
to have concerns about um human beings
and thinking about a you know other ways
forward other than uh just bombing the
heck out of the place um that's I think
that's reasonable and not not
anti-semitic but again it depends on the
context and what the motivations are
okay and um there are a few questions
about you know trying to understand um
what is motivating some and this is a
hard question but what's motivating a
lot of the anti-israel sentiment right
now is it
um do you think that it's you know um
unleashing Prejudice that was already
there um and another way of putting this
is um you know what's motivating for
instance you know I I was reading an
article yesterday about um anti-Semitism
on the Chinese internet you know and so
um is that purely um sympathy for
Palestinians or do you think that there
are other things going on here um yeah I
think I think there's probably not one
simple you know situation I think there
are some that you know glom on to the
you know good and bad and Palestinians
are oppressed and Israelis are
oppressors uh and they you know feel
some sort of comfort in that some of
them may be uh going after Israel
because it's a Jewish State that's
certainly I suspect some uh aspect of it
but I think you know some of it is
you know again seeing the pictures
having the
concerns um and you know it's it's a
it's a variety of things that I think
motivate people but it as what concerns
me is that as long as this goes on um
that's going to be um you know a
challenge and you know I have I have
friends non-jewish
um who you know are sympathetic to
Israel but also at a gas you know at
what's going on and thinking about a
ceasefire and all that and I don't know
you know at what point does um do you
create you know some more antipathy um
to Israel when you know there 10,000
dead babies 20,000 you know at what
point uh does that create you know
tremendous aside from the dead people
does that you know create challenges for
Israel I don't know I'm glad I don't
have to make decisions about what to do
yeah so here's a question um that I know
is on a lot of people's minds um how do
you think social media has impacted the
the landscape of anti-Semitism uh
especially maybe on college
campuses I think it gives an opportunity
for people to um you know put things
that are hateful very quickly uh you
know out there but um you know to to me
it there's a whole discussion about hate
and and social media and whether um
things should be regulated even before
you know October uh
7th and to me it's it's about the ideas
more than the the medium I mean people
were worried about hate uh when the
printing press was put together and you
know one can make the case of the most
hateful you know thing about Jews was
probably things some things in the New
Testament right so you know um you
television radio father
cogin uh early internet sites so they're
all different ways and they all
communicate in ways a little differently
so I think it's it's part of the puzzle
it allows people to communicate and
build sense of community but I think it
also gives an
opportunity um that we haven't fully
tapped yet it's one of the things in in
the center that we're looking at is how
do we use social media more effectively
against hate I mean to me it's it um I'm
sort of a gas that you know we see hate
crimes and there's no real easy
mechanism for people uh to use you know
social media um to know what their
resources are how to report a hate crime
all those things so there are ways of
building up our capacity to fight hate a
lot better using social media it's it's
a it's a double-edged sword and to give
you one you know final example of that
just so that you know people understand
the context I mean back at the time of
the Oklahoma City
bombing it was the early internet days
and there were a bunch of us watching
the militia movement with its
anti-Semitism and its its hatred of
federal officials really start taking
shape from one group to two groups to 10
groups to 20 groups in a couple of
months all around the the you know the
country more than that even and so a
bunch of us got together and were
watching the what they were posting on
these early Bolton board so it gave the
haters an opportunity to feel Community
to spread rumors to organize in a way
that they hadn't had before but it gave
us an opportunity to also get a better
sense of what they were doing which is
why a bunch of us put a warning of watch
for April 19th the anniversary of wakeo
Something's likely to happen so it's
most of these things are double-edged
sorts yeah it's a that's a great Point
yeah how can we use social media um to
solve the problem rather rather than
just let it keep causing it so a
question about statements um you know I
think that um after October 7th
immediately there there seemed to be
this war over statements and especially
I think on University campuses you know
um were University presidents quick to
put out a statement were the statements
sufficiently pro-israel or were they too
pro-israel um how do you uh explain just
the passion that the the statement
question aroused and do you think
statements are a good thing um what's
what's your statement on
statements well I think people see sort
of see it as a symbol and they try
almost with you know talmudic uh
intensity try to dissect it and does it
you know is it sufficient is it
insufficient does it cover you know what
I care about or does it go to the other
side is it all those things
there's
a University of Chicago based uh report
that came out in the 60s called The
Calvin report that basically said
universities really ought to avoid
stepping into you know making political
statements and I think basically that's
right I mean I did two statements when I
was at AJC that got over 400 College
presidents to sign one was when we saw
attacks on the Hillel building at
Berkeley and Concordia was a riot you
know in
2002 with Yehuda reinhardt's who's in a
brandise and L Jim freen from Dartmouth
and a bunch of others we put together a
statement that talked about the college
president's responsibility to the campus
to uh not allow harassment not allow
intimidation to keep it open to ideas
and so forth and then in 2007 I worked
with Lee Binger and about 400 other
college presidents including Harold
chapiro Prince was um when the
university and college Union in the UK
put out a statement advancing an
academic Bo God of Israel and so we got
about 400 some OD to sign on to Lee
statement which was if that Union was
intent on dividing the academic world
into Israelis who should be
shunned and um everybody else count us
as Israelis this the same time the ADL
was floating G maybe we should uh
boycott British academic and
institutions which in my view was you
know ridiculous to change the debate
from should we have academic boycotts to
who should be boycotted but the
principle of both of those statements
was looking at the campus and academic
freedom and what the campus should be in
the Calvin report says that that that's
fine so what I was advising when this
was happening is yeah it's I think it's
important for presidents not to be seen
as silent and ignoring this I think it's
perfectly appropriate to put out
something that says we know our students
are are hurting uh I think and to what
are the resources I think it's important
to talk about what the campus can do at
this time this educational Mission and
how we should be treating each other but
to make a statement about even though
personally you know I would have
deplored obviously what Hamas was doing
as a president I probably would not have
and I think Maud Mandel Williams put out
a really smart statement it was a
statement about why she wasn't putting
out a statement but it was very clear
that she was focusing on on what the
campus should do as opposed to you know
don't expect the president's office to
be the state department right but I you
know I understand that and I am sort of
against statements also I wish they had
never gone down that road to begin with
but I can also understand the other
point of view which is once universities
start putting out statements when some
groups are yeah hurt Why are Jews left
at you know why doesn't the massacre of
Jews Merit a statement or why you know
so I I do understand that that that side
also um right but but I understand that
too and that's why I think it's probably
a better policy not to put it out
but you know I don't remember anybody
you know getting up on campus and and
there may have been some students but I
don't remember people organizing saying
you know that uh George Floyd got a
coming
uh or back in the apartheid South Africa
days somebody saying apartheid is a good
thing right on this issue you have a a
lot of divisiveness on the campus and
you know so I don't see campuses putting
out positions on abortion I don't see
campuses saying you know leave aside the
501c3 problems you know you should be
opposing Trump right but I'm just going
to push back on that because think could
say well but isn't you know uh the
massacre of innocent people in Israel
like an inherent um moral you know um
catastrophe that needs to be denounced
um at that time isn't it and isn't it
the responsibility of the university to
take a clear moral stance on something
like that I the answer is I as an
individual would um but as a university
president I'd be very hesitant to I mean
they haven't put out statements about
you know the earthquake in Turkey they
haven't put out statements about a lot
of other things I don't remember about
the Wagers you know I mean you could
talk this this was this was an atrocity
that that that um was just you know
unfathomable and I think there are
opportunities on a campus to educate
about this and I am concerned about
students who are so in that that that
tunnel
that they can't even to tick a box say
you know killing babies is not such a
good thing but we still were supporting
for Palestinian rights right um or
saying you know I have a colleague who
teaches at Ruckers who was telling me
that one of the pro Hamas students was a
student who thought Hamas was a person
there's a lot of ignorance out there and
not knowing about what the Hamas is in
its original charter and how it treats
gays and women and so so there's a lot
of lot of Education there but there is
some um you know again it it's to
me I'm more interested in what a college
President does to use the
educational yeah well I was gonna
say yeah that that you know statements
are inherently reductionist you know and
it's it's kind of contrary to the
mission of what the university is
supposed to do which is to give deep
context and and to teach about things so
this leads to because we're sort of
running out of time leads to some other
questions people pushing back on on the
call precisely for um you know the
response to anti-Semitism being more
education how or you know how do you do
that when people seem so dug in on this
issue that they just don't want to learn
and um or they're just so completely
ignorant that they're they're just not
willing you know to learn and are you
know taking these these um knee-jerk
positions on either side how then does
education become the answer to in a
situation like that that's so you know
resistant to it yeah that's a it's a
great question I think you know part of
uh again what a university needs to do
is broader than just looking at this
question it's the culture of being
disturbed by ideas of finding new
classes again new class classes on
anti-Semitism new classes on hatred and
and um you know the why people hate and
why we get into these boxes um more
programs that that bring in uh people
with different points of view to model
how you can disagree on strongly
Divergent uh views classes on how to do
that um those things I think over time
will set the tone um and it comes from
the University leadership it comes from
the faculty uh and the more we can
Empower those voices is it is it going
to you know be like a silver bullet no
but I think ultimately that's the best
tool that a campus has and when it goes
down the other Road of saying we find
this speech so deplorable that we're
going to censor it it just feeds into
the binary which is the problem you know
in the first place there's also an
opportunity here and that you know
campuses have a turnover at least a
quarter of their student students every
year so are you going to with programs
now change a lot of Minds probably not
although I think some were changing the
program that that I participated I'm
sure programs in other places but you
have you know next year and the year
after and I think you know it's more of
an expectation when students come in of
how do you treat each other how do you
understand you know uh those things will
help set that up a little bit better and
okay that we into um another question
that someone had which is how should
University administrations um manage
these protests um you know uh anti
anti-israel protests to make sure that
they don't become opportunities for
anti-semitic
expression I I think you know
expressions
are awful but they're first amendment
protected so you're not going to you're
going to punish a student who's going to
say you know in Cornell make make true
threats be very clear on that but you
also want to
um
encourage the student body to realize
that there are things that are being
said that are really hurtful or pred
this hurtful by people and to understand
the more of the context of it so they're
going to take a position that I as a
Zionist feel uh
you know Cuts me to the quick they at
least ought to know how to how to you
know deal with that um and on the flip
side again is to have a perception
that when you hear something you're not
fragile you're gonna you know figure out
how you're GNA I remember at Bard years
ago I walked onto the campus and there
was a big free Palestine sign I had not
seen that before and it sort of made me
very uncomfortable um and then I thought
about it and I thought that's somebody
has an opinion I strongly disagree with
I understand it makes me deeply
uncomfortable but you know I would be
more uncomfortable if the administration
said they can't express themselves and
again you know Finding opportunity there
are ways I mean there are small groups
to bring together which I've done of
people that are strongly opposed on this
issue but want to have the conversation
and with tech study and so forth um does
it necessarily change Minds no but it's
a a possibility I'll give you one other
example and this is I have a blueprint
for this at the end of the book was a
class I love that a woman named Natasha
Gil came up with it was a um simulation
course so half the chorus was students
basically being actors and the chorus
was looking at the appeal commission uh
of the 30s so for those who don't uh
recall the the Brits when they had the
Mandate said Lord be able to figure out
what the heck are we going to do with
this and they talked to everybody Arabs
and Jews and um came up with a a report
of of what to do so this is before the
Holocaust
before 48 before 67 before contemporary
times so the guts of the conflict and it
was well structured she gave students uh
roles opposite uh that would be an easy
one for her so she gave a p a Pakistani
Muslim had to eight weeks Faithfully
representing David Boran and when I
talked to the student about it she said
you know as strange as that was for me
it was probably stranger for my Israeli
classmate who had to be the Muffy and as
much as a pain in the butt he was the
jabotinsky figure on my side was worse
to deal with so you know like a a little
bit of reality and what I loved about it
is Natasha told me that you know
students would come in and say gee we
can figure out how this conflict should
have been resolved you know 80 years ago
and they come out of it saying now we
understand why it hasn't been resolved
in 0 years that's education and the more
things we can do like that the better
okay well we are um out of time and
there you know just many many more um
questions here that um I'm gonna ask my
assistant Anessa to um at least take
pictures of and and we can send you one
thing um before we go someone ask for
just the reference to the Derek penslar
um article sure if I'll give you my
email so if you want that or anything
else please feel free to email it's K
Stern so k s
Ern Bard bard.edu
okay terrific thank you and thank you to
all um the participants for your great
questions and I apologize not for not
being able to answer um or to ask all of
them I urge everybody you're probably
already on our mailing list but if
you're not please do sign up there we're
going to have more um uh events around
this conflict but also other events that
had been already scheduled um on very
interesting topics including you know
right-wing anti-Semitism and um you know
other um things relating to the Middle
East too so um thank you all for
attending and a special thanks to Ken
Stern um for these you know very helpful
and and interesting uh comments today
you can't hear everyone clapping but I
will uh clap for everyone else and um
you know let's hope that this you know
ends soon yeah yeah thank you Mari thank
you everybody thanks everyone
bye